on your feet  senior chief john kelly  is more dangerous and effective  than any man we have in the field  [Music]  the only thing he has more than kills  are medals  somebody would like to talk to you john  if you're done in there  we need you to get back in the field  senior chief kelly it appears you have a  common enemy with the united states  they took everything from me  my family i got nothing left  their plan is a series of strategic  attacks all over the world  we have to respond i need to be on that  team lieutenant commander greer  you lead the mission i'm leaving out the  playing field cia doesn't support any  further investigation into your wife's  murder  battlefield he had no right to take so  much from me  [Music]  this is a gold mission  what's  [Music]  now  no remorse  you